adrian attend ce moment depuis bientôt
deux mois
dans quelques minutes il va rouvrir
l'hôtel dont il est co directeur son
établissement en front de mer compte 70
chambres et affichent généralement
complet au mois de mai mais cette année
confinement oblige il a dû fermer ses
portes le 20 mars
le bilan est douloureux déjà 20 % de
perte sur le chiffre d'affaires annuel
depuis le 11 mai les français peuvent à
nouveau se déplacer dans un rayon de 100
km autour de leur domicile alors pour
limiter les frais adrian a décidé de
recevoir à nouveau des clients mais sous
certaines conditions
on a 75 chambres de disponible
normalement à l'hôtel là on a diminué
pratiquement de moitié donc on a eu plus
de moitié à 35 chambres disponibles en
ce moment pour les week-ends et
confinement ça reste pas rentable mais
ça permet de d'exister ça permet d'être
là d'habitude le grand hôtel des savates
plage à 60 % de la clientèle
internationale
alors on dont 40% de national là on part
sur 100% de local c'est-à-dire dans le
rayon de 100 kilomètres dans le
département du var il vaut mieux ouvrir
l'hôtel avec une petite partie du staff
et réduire de moitié la capacité pour
être sûr de faire du bon travail plutôt
que de laisser les hôtels fermés pour
l'instant impossible d'assurer un
service 7 jours sur 7
le protocole sanitaire en vigueur impose
de laisser les chambres vides au moins
quatre jours consécutifs après le départ
des clients
l'établissement reçoit donc uniquement
le week end la cuisine est ouverte mais
impossible de s'asseoir au restaurant
tout et à emporter
pour le reste les règles d'hygiène et de
distanciation physique sont les mêmes
qu'ailleurs on est arrivé avec bien sûr
des masques mais tout personnel était
masqué également il nous avait expliqué
dans les chambres il y avait beaucoup de
chose justement pour nous protéger
beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de masques
on se croit un peu à la maison entre
guillemets dans un site d'exception et
c'est très confortable
on se sent pas stressé comme on peut
l'être dans la vie courante par rapport
à toutes ces mesures de protection qu'on
doit quand même l'un tenir ça fait un
petit moment privilégié dans le dic
confinement c'est à dire que pour moi
les discophiles mans c'est pas les
retourner
en magasin fallait il fallait un peu
marquer le coup que ce soit un petit mot
un petit moment à part quoi du fait que
l'hôtel n'est pas encore à 100 % de sa
capacité donc on est on est un peu dans
ce sens vraiment privilégié moi je
trouve ça très bien
ces week-ends de déconfinement un plan b
pour l'industrie hôtelière qui tente de
sauver les meubles mais l'enjeu
principal est encore à venir pour ses
hôtels de bord de mer remplir leur
carnet de réservations pour les mois de
juillet et d'août
[Musique]